en qué consiste esta reforma y por qué
el rechazo hacia ella
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
lo primero es que hay un gran rechazo en
el país porque en colombia se ha
instaurado desde hace 27 años la salud
como negocio y esta reforma pretende
profundizar el negocio la salud que ha
costado que entre 1998 en 2010 en
colombia haya habido un millón 300 mil
muertes evitables aparte de que en
colombia anualmente se ponen 220 mil
tutelas por negación de servicios de
salud luego ese sistema de salud basado
en el negocio nos ha costado muchas
vidas y el congreso de la república con
el gobierno nacional en medio de una
pandemia pretende aprobar un proyecto de
ley para terminar de privatizar los
recursos públicos de la salud aumentar
la negación de servicios en el país lo
que nosotros denominamos en colombia el
paseo de la muerte llevar a la
liquidación hospitales públicos
importantes para las comunidades zonas
dispersas y rurales que son
aproximadamente 22 millones de
colombianos e intervenir los currículos
médicos para flexibilizar los y atentar
contra el principio de autonomía
universitaria
entre otros asuntos que han incluido
allí que son inconstitucionales
inaceptables por lo que diversas
agremiaciones médicas de la salud y
ahora en el marco del movimiento
ciudadano que hay en las calles estamos
solicitando el archivo de este proyecto
de ley ahora doctor ha de ser aprobada
como afectará a esta reforma de manera
directa a todos los ciudadanos
colombianos y a la comunidad médica del
país
básicamente si esta reforma se aprueba
van a aumentar en colombia' la negación
de servicios de salud que insisto en
colombia el año antepasado antes de la
pandemia o aproximadamente un millón de
quejas al año por in atención en salud y
en el primer semestre del año pasado ya
llevábamos 700.000 esta reforma tiene
diversos instrumentos para que se
nieguen servicios de salud en colombia a
todas las poblaciones en todos los
niveles y por esta vía digamos es el
sacrificio de la vida su segundo la
reforma no resuelve los problemas de
precarización laboral de los
trabajadores y médicos de la salud
colombia que en un 80 por ciento
estamos bajo formas de contratación
ilegal precarias que no interviene en
esta reforma que disco adorables doctora
rápidamente antes de finalizar realmente
es necesaria en colombia una reforma al
sistema de salud y de ser así y como
debería estar enfocada
por supuesto colombia necesita una
reforma estructural al sistema de salud
desde la sociedad civil organizaciones
médicas ya venimos trabajando en una
pero no es esta necesita una reforma
descentralizada un sistema público que
garantice el derecho universal gratuito
porque en colombia la financiación del
sistema de salud es pública los
colombianos pagamos pero hay diversos
actores que extraen renta hacen negocios
y finalmente esto se traduce en negación
de servicios por tanto consideramos que
si tiene que ver una reforma estructural
pero no es esta por eso la idea es
solicitar el archivo para luego como
sociedad civil convocar a un diálogo
ciudadano con con las otras
organizaciones ciudadanas del sector
salud y presentar una propuesta